meanwhile disney has issued a statement
they say florida's hb 1557 also known as
the don't say gay bill should never have
passed and should never have been signed
into law our goal as a company is for
this law to be repealed by the
legislature or struck down in the court
so we remain committed to supporting the
national state organizations working to
achieve that we're dedicated to standing
up for the rights and safety of lgbtq
plus members of the disney family as
well as the lgbtq plus community in
florida and across the country
so disney which produces
much of the entertainment um that your
kids probably watch
they have come out and
at first they tried to basically stay
out of it but now
caving to the pressure
i mean this is a company with thousands
and thousands and thousands of employees
billions of dollars
and a handful of them
came out and complained and were able to
bring disney the
disney corporation to its knees
you want to talk about social capital
that's the kind of power that you wield
if you're in the lgbt camp
going back to why why why so many kids
it's tempting for them to buy into it
because they see that
and they see the power and popularity
that comes with it
but disney caving to all the pressure
now they're
they're offering full of full defense
they are fully in favor of sexualizing
young kids
now of course we know that disney has
been in favor of that actually for for a
long time
but now they're out in the open about it
they think that your five-year-old
should be sexualized they think that
your five-year-old should be taught
about transgenderism and gender identity
and sexual orientation
now the question becomes
are we as parents
going to continue to
purchase disney products
and sit our kids down in front of
televisions to watch entertainment from
disney
after disney has told us
that they are in favor of sexualizing
your kid that's what they want to do
they're they are committed to it they
say
they are steadfastly committed to the
sexualization of kids
been the case for a long time now
they're out coming out and saying it
they are fully out of the groomer closet
we have to make a decision now as
parents
um is
disney entertainment
so important so crucial to us as parents
that um we'll we'll continue to give
them our money even after they've told
us they want to sexualize our kids
or will we finally have a little bit of
self-respect and say you know what you
don't even have to call it a boycott
i mean called a boycott if you want i
don't care what you call it
but when when a when a company comes out
and says number one
we hate you
we hate everything you stand for we hate
your values we hate who you are we hate
everything you believe
and we want to sexualize your kids
uh here's a whole bunch of entertainment
we've made for your kid please sit them
down in front of the tv and let them
watch it
as parents we have to decide uh is it is
are we gonna say well okay
be like brainwashed
hypnotized automatons and saying oh okay
sit down kids and watch this what else
are we gonna do
well a life deprived of disney products
is unlivable
who can imagine such a thing
[Music]
it's about having a little self-respect
and respect you know for your kids if
you enjoyed this video be sure to give
it a thumbs up and share it with all
your friends